I think we've only just begun the
adjustment process and growth rates are
going to slow down a lot more my
expectation is that under President Xi's
term roughly from two 2013-2023 average
growth rates are unlikely to exceed
three to four percent and that's not my
prediction that's the upper limit of my
prediction I really don't think China's
going to be able to grow much faster
than that and that may seem like a very
surprising statement and certainly a few
years ago it was considered even more
surprising but there there are two sets
of reasons why I think that's likely to
be the case the first is very
straightforward it's just the historical
precedence we've had depending on how
you define a growth miracle we've had
perhaps 30 to 40 of them since the
Second World War i define it as more
than 10 years of more than seven percent
growth and they all follow very similar
patterns is very little variation in the
early stages these countries tend to
have very low level levels of investment
relative to their absorption capacity so
in that case the best strategy is to
increase investment as rapidly as
possible and that's what they all do but
are undeveloped countries the difference
between a China and the UK is not that
the UK has more investment it's probably
institutional it's probably has
something to do with the financial
system the legal system all of these
other issues so rich countries are able
to absorb higher levels of capital more
productively almost by definition a poor
country can't do that so a country like
China with very high levels of
investment the highest ever recorded and
very high growth rates of investment it
was always likely to reach a point at
which it was no longer able to absorb it
productively and I believe we reach that
point quite a long time ago most people
agree that we've passed that point the
debate is is how long and once that
happens almost by definition get is
growing faster than debt servicing
capacity and when that happens of course
that means debt is growing unsustainable
so it's probably not a surprise under
those conditions that every single
growth miracle certainly since world war
two and probably before has ended either
in a debt crisis or in a lost decade or
two lost decades in the case of Japan of
a very very low growth but the real
difference is conceptually between China
and the precedents are that the
imbalances have been taken to levels in
China that we've never seen before in
history particularly the consumption
imbalance we've never seen such a low
consumption level and credit is growing
faster than we've ever seen before so
the Chinese exceptionalism probably
suggests a greater rather than a lesser
likelihood of following that pattern
what's the prognosis simple terms if
you've got the a lot of people say you
need a certain level of growth in China
to have you know for it to be socially
stable China has roughly one-fifth of
the world's population and certainly by
most measures it is much less than
one-fifth of almost anything so we're
going to see a lot of that catching up
but i think the economic expectations
for china have been vastly overstated I
don't think China is going to come
anywhere close to achieving some of the
expectation certainly that we had three
or four years ago I think and again the
historical precedent suggests this is
that perceptions are slowly catching up
to the reality but they're going to
continue to lag it for a few more years
the government says seven percent is as
back Tenace it's certain you're saying
that half of that is optimistic yes I
think that if President she is able to
pull off average growth rates of three
to four percent during his ten years in
office he will have accomplished
something that we should really be
astonished that they would it would it
would be truly impressive almost on par
with what done shopping that in the
1980s because he's inherited a much more
difficult economy than we think there
a huge amount of debt there's a huge
amount of unrecognized bad debt and
there is a financial system structured
around a very unbalanced type of
relationship with external volatility
and it's going to be very costly to
adjust but if the adjustment is done
correctly the cost of the adjustment
will be passed on to the what in China
refer to as the vested interests they
benefited disproportionately from 30
years of growth but they will also have
to pay a disproportionate share of the
costs one of the implications is that if
I'm right and Chinese growth does drop
as much as I expected to we will not
have the social disturbances that many
people assume because the growth rate of
ordinary households will drop by much
less in the growth rate of the economy
so three to four percent growth rates
average growth rates for China would be
consistent with five to six percent
growth in household income and
rebalancing by definition means
household income has to grow faster than
gdp a lot of people see things in terms
of markets and obviously that fall in
what happened in Shanghai scared a lot
of people was that significant and was
that something was that in and of itself
a harbinger for future chaos or is that
just something else entirely it it
should have been and among many people
it was fairly fairly well expected not
the specifics but in the in the
adjustment process during the growth
period there is a tendency to structure
balance sheets in such a way that they
exacerbate growth it's basically very
speculative balance sheets and that's a
winning strategy when everything's going
well during the adjustment process that
same sort of balance sheet structure
always leads to great difficulty in
disruption within the financial sector
and China is not proven to be an
exception the key is government
credibility credibility is very high in
China it got it was damaged a little bit
in the last six months but it remains
very high and as long as it's high we
will not have a financial crisis and I
suspect that that's the the more likely
expectation